[Music]
hello everybody i am josh welsh
president of film independent and thank
you for joining us today for this
amazing conversation part of film
independent presents the virtual edition
um
before we get started just a couple
quick thanks i want to thank our lead
sponsor
the organization that makes film
independent presents possible the
hollywood foreign press association
thank you all so much we love you um i
also want to thank our screening partner
vision media
and our media partner the los angeles
times
um for anyone watching live please take
advantage of the q
a button at the bottom of the screen
towards the at the end of this
conversation
um we'll we'll get to your questions but
send them our way throughout
um i just want to say personally to me
this is such an exciting conversation
that you all are about to witness
melissa hayslip is an amazing filmmaker
who we at film independent have been so
honored and lucky to know
these past many years she went through
our project involved mentorship program
she was the recipient of the roger and
chaz ebert fellowship at the film
independence spirit awards
and she's made an incredible film with
mr soul so
very excited to to have this
conversation with melissa today
and then okay covet is horrible we all
hate covet it's a terrible thing but
there's one good thing about it which is
and there's a good thing about zoom
where we get to bring together amazing
people
for conversations online where let's
face it the real world this would be
really hard to pull off
there's some amazing special guests
today but none more amazing than lena
waite who will be moderating today
lena is a long time friend of film
independent spirit award nominee for
dear white people
somebody whose work we've screened at
film independent presents and she's
always there
supporting up and coming filmmakers and
and the in the community so
with that i will stop blabbering and i
just want to say thank you both for
being here thank you to everyone
ladies and gentlemen please welcome lena
waite
hello everyone um first of all i want to
say hi
this also feels like an episode of uh
soul by the way because
uh mr underwood is driving uh
proper over here got somewhere to be we
have the legendary the
um miss giovanni all blessings and peace
be on to you
i'm so honored to be uh for us all of us
to be sharing this space with you and
we're so grateful that
you're here with us you're what i like
to call one of our living ancestors and
so thank you so much
for being here glad to be here amazing
so
um look we'll get since mr underwood is
driving and he's got to get on the
flight
i want to throw him the first question
so
how which is i know the question
everybody asks like well how did you get
involved
my question for you is did you like
how familiar were you with this show
and why was it so important for you to
narrate and do such a beautiful job
narrating the film he's on mute right
now which is like classic
there you go all right can you hear me i
got you i'll see you with the peanut
butter uh interior let's get it
you understand you understand come on
now come on now
liz i pulled over i should probably pull
over and be legal up in here uh
first of all i will answer your question
lena but let me just say thank you to
josh and film independent for this
platform
thank you melissa hayslip for creating
uh mr soul this project because i'm
honored just completely honored um and
amazed to be a part of this project
um and lena wei let me thank you because
you know i'm a fan of yours
and just to watch your stars shine in
your trajectory in the last 10 15 years
has been phenomenal to
see but your support of this film in
this moment right now is invaluable so i
thank you for that
um so how i got involved no no no i
i you did not ask that question you
asked about uh did i know about it and
the thing was i did not know about it
you know melissa was kind enough to at
the very end when she had shot
everything
and she had her final cut she reached
out to me then um and invited me to
narrate
the project and be the voice of of her
uncle ellis hayslip
but when i saw the trailer i was like my
god
why do i why do i not know about this
show because anybody who was anybody and
everybody was everybody
in the black community and culture came
through those stages in those five six
years
um so i could i i don't think i could
pick up the phone fast enough to say
melissa how can i be involved i want to
be down
i think not unlike you when you when you
got hip to say i want to be involved in
this somehow
absolutely no that's good to know and i
think uh for me
i became aware of of of soul
through a conversation between amazing
miss giovanni
and james baldwin and i actually saw
that conversation
while i was wrapping up filming queen
and slim
so it was a very huge moment for me and
that conversation became such a pivotal
part of i think my education and my
understanding
and just and who i wanted to be as a
black artist and how i wanted to be
remembered
and um and i'll ask this to mr giovanni
like
how should we be surprised uh
that a queer black man help orchestrate
that conversation between you two that
would really
go on to inspire so many people should
we be surprised by that
no i don't think so ellis was a really
wonderful in in terms of uh producing
that that's one of the things that he
did and when when
the idea of seoul started i knew ellis i
had met ellis and of course i think
everybody
did but one of the things that he wanted
to do because he was he was afraid that
he would not
be accepted one of the things he did was
um uh
alvin poussin he asked alvin if he would
be the host
and we were friends ellis and i were
friends and he came up and we talked
about it and he said you know
i'm going to ask alvin i said ellis it's
your show and i'm a
i'm a big fan of it's your show i said
it's your show why don't you do it he
said no
people won't like me and i'll be there
said alice you know you
take my word for what he said no and so
alvin and i'm not against alvin
but alvin hosted i think three shows
and of course he was terrible and
he wanted i mean it wasn't personal but
alvin is uh
uh he's not a theater person
and he's a critic and uh it just it
wasn't his thing
and so and i say came up because i lived
on amsterdam avenue and alice was down
in the village
but he came up and he said it's not
working i said oh no and i knew it
wouldn't
he said well why don't you do it and i
said ellis this is not what i
do i i'm i'm not good at i i can't ask
anybody a question because i'm mostly
not that interested
i'm interested in listening and watching
but i'm not
i'm not a journalist i said why don't
it's your show why don't you
do it he said that they're not going to
like me said ellis you know
you're a big boy you've heard no before
do the your show
do the show and so he decided i'm sure
i'm not the only one we have to always
remember uh melissa and i'm sure you do
novella nelson and and novella made made
a big uh
uh impact on that so he said he would do
it well of course he looked gorgeous
because
he was a gorgeous he he dressed
and uh really before a lot of people
done the head i remember that back soon
and he would have a pocket
on a handkerchief and his tie he always
looked he looked great
and so everybody was like oh you know
let's check it out
and then checking out seoul he got to be
more and more comfortable
and the only thing that made him
uncomfortable is that i remember
he wanted um louis farrakhan and he said
farrakhan won't
won't come because you know far khan is
a muslim anyone i said ellis anybody
will do television
ask him have your people called to ask
and of course you know far khan was
extremely happy
i knew uh personally um muhammad ali
and muhammad ali and i shared a
publicist
victoria lucas so he i said why don't
you get you know ali
and he said you think so i said oh yeah
vicky i'll talk to vic and so that's how
he got
i'll leave but everybody wanted to be on
his show and again you have to give
novella
a lot of credit because she had said to
him no matter what
you're doing make sure that this show
looks
good we're not just going to let a bunch
of for lack of a better word a bunch of
negroes
walk on stage and their hair is all
messed up and their their
clothes are not you know polishing so it
was
it was too novella's credit that we had
a makeup person
that we had a hair person and we had
something
for the clothes and uh i was like
everybody was just looking fly
naturally on their own my life but i but
that's that's good to know
and you wouldn't mind melissa i wanted
to ask you
because obviously you felt the need and
there's obviously a familial
reason as to why you wanted to do the
documentary but
even if you were not if you didn't share
the same last name
as the person that the documentary is
centered around
would you have just been as interested
in this story and wanting to tell it but
obviously there was a
a bigger reason at play but why do you
think everybody
should know i think people have seen the
movie will know why they need to know
ellis name but why did you think that
people needed to know the legacy and i'm
so grateful to you for
do making this movie because i was very
familiar with the work but i didn't know
working behind it to me he's like almost
like the buyer rusting of
of like public live television it's like
he's the architect that nobody sees
so can you tell me why it was so
important for people to know who he was
yes and thank you so much especially for
being here today i just wanted
i'm just so excited i'm obsessed with it
i'm almost out of the dark i'm like
i'm like what's happening
it's it's really important when we think
about our legacy
and and how we approach that and the
stories that we're telling
and and the importance of telling our
own stories and there's so many pockets
of history
where we have been so instrumental in
forming culture and changing
history in that way and ellis hayslip
was like an
unsung hero to me and of course i'm
related so there is that
but i saw him as fundamentally changing
the perception of african-americans
and african-american culture by
presenting it in a way that was
completely unique because it was true
it was real it was based on love you
know it was about black love black
strength
black sister and brotherhood black
agreement black disagreement
all the complexities of our culture and
so
i was just blown away when i finally got
to see
the full breadth of all the all the
shows because i was kind of too young
when it first came on
and um when i realized like this is a
time capsule but it's also
a love letter to black culture and we
need that now more than ever you know
talk about restoring the soul of a
nation like his voice as a revolutionary
as a an unsung hero as a queer icon
all of those things put together make
him somebody that
that really should be known because it
really has impacted the way we see
ourselves
and the trajectory of of just black
presence
and and inclusion on television even if
it was subtle or not you know
for sure yeah and blair and robert i
know you guys have to jump but i want to
throw you guys this question which i'm
sure
everybody in the the question the q and
a box which i have in front of me are
asking is
could and of course i thought this too i
was watching a documentary it's like
could we do this today and i was
thinking i had my wheels turning like
could this exist now
could how would this look how would it
feel but i just want to ask you two and
feel free to answer this question i'll
let you guys uh
get to where you're going but could this
exist today
obviously we would need it but also my
question is
is there i'm gonna say is there an
audience for it yes i'm sure a lot of
folks are gonna go yeah there's an
audience for it but i do
think that was a very different time you
know that you have
two phenomenal authors sitting down and
having a conversation
about the relationship between black men
and black women within our community
i do think it's a very interesting thing
and melissa and ms giovanni i would like
to get your thoughts on this because
the conversation between him and
minister farrakhan made me somewhat
uncomfortable
as a queer black person you know and i
want to get into that but
um but robert and blair can we can you
guys speak to
is there space for something like seoul
today before y'all
get out of here rob you wanna jump on
that first
yeah yeah i mean i think there are
definitely a space um
for um because of seoul because of
because of
shows like seoul you know there's so
many
offspring of artists first of all
so many offspring of artists and you
know
so many people with voices you know and
especially now so many people with
voices that are speaking out
and talking about issues and creating
creating art that
that represents different things and
issues and
i think it's i think today is is a is a
great time to do something like so
um we talked about that before
in my mind i was always thinking of who
would be the host of soul because number
one i will be the music director
don't want it out there melissa just so
you'll know
in your mind okay i wanted it out there
i wanted to be the md
you know what i mean but i think it'll
be amazing i think it'd be amazing
i think i think it's needed you know i i
i honestly think
that kind of show is is needed for sure
yeah brother i think it's absolutely
necessary and i think it's doable
right now you know i think you look at
you look at soul and you had the musical
performances and you had the poetry uh
readings um but you had the
conversations you had the interviews and
i think that's what we don't see today
we have so many fractured chapters and
channels
and and whatnot but we get a chance
finally like never before to show
all elements the breadth the width and
depth of our people
but to actually just sit down i mean
what's so iconic and you can just pull
this it's in our film of course
but it's it's been planted all over
youtube the conversation between miss
giovanni
and james baldwin is just like it's
iconic and classic
so um so the answer to the question is
absolutely yes
we got to find a way to do it so lena
maybe all of us and melissa melissa
we've talked about that we can find a
way to make that happen
but before i go can i say this real
quick same with giovanni
yeah mr giovanni we've done a couple of
these and i have never met mr giovanni
i am a huge fan and i have tremendous
profound respect for miss giovanni
and i just wanted to give a deep bow and
show respect and say hello and say i
love you and thank you for
for making the path and everything
you've done to open doors for all of us
in our generation and beyond
well thank you i'm such a fan of yours
before you have the
beer
get back to the la la days that's right
that's right
thank you very much um and you know i
want to say this before you leave
we have to remember the beatles wouldn't
have been anything without ed sullivan
and i think that that's kind of the way
we have to
begin thinking that's right how do we
want to put the whole
thing together and our grandparents woke
me up one night
to say wake nicky up lena horne is on
television because that's how few black
people
used to be on tv and it would be
wonderful
to be able to put together a show that
has blacks and whites and whomever
sitting down and talking doing certain
uh
point different points of view i think
it'd be a much needed show
and i think it should be hosted by
someone black and i wouldn't have a clue
uh
who but i think yeah we need yes soul or
something of that nature
america or the right way or something
yeah
we need it yeah yeah we maybe we could
have that conversation between
tallahassee coates and cornell west
finally um
come on now see but but i think that's
the thing is like we we need those
opportunities
for our people to sit down or like i
still want to see a conversation between
gail and snoop
you know what i'm saying like i think
the conversations between us
particularly
the ones the generational ones need to
happen
and it's really important that they
happen in front of us like again uh like
we can reference the the mr giovanni
involved with conversations again and
again
because there's so much we're literally
watching
uh mr baldwin learn something
or see things differently because of
giovanni and i think that is so
interesting we're so not used to seeing
that
that a a younger generation educating an
older generation but also watching him
beautifully pull rank in certain
instances where he's been
like hold on he's like i've been here
longer this is not doing me
we know that we know that feeling we
know when that that uncle
who who you know who you who is a little
bit wiser and knows more
sometimes but he says in such a
beautiful and respectful way and i think
we have gotten so far away from that so
that's my hope to have that back um so
yeah but
blair robert we won't let y'all go and
then we'll keep this going thank you so
much blair thank you so much thank you
thank you guys happy holidays everybody
before you go real quick i just want to
say thank you to both of you guys
you know you are the anchors of of the
film with the voice and the music
and what i really want to do is give you
your flowers now
so what i have for everybody is i'll
come offline
give you flowers
and gentlemen i would you know do
flowers for you too but i think it's
important that we give flowers
now
we may not see each other again and we
may not come together in that way and
i'm all about giving props while we're
here
and all of you are just you know blazing
trails
and and pushing the culture forward and
so i said
shout out to all you wow melissa thank
you thank you
thank you miss giovanni for being who
you are thank you lena
i love your work i just i just finished
the show i'm a little late
but i just finished the shot i saw
soccer clean this room
matter of fact we got we got our emmys
together
our first enemies together the same
night
really i'll come on now yeah cause i i i
did the music for the 13th film the the
last
song so me and common got it in me that
night and i saw you
get up there and get your emmy and i i
was afraid to talk to you i saw you in
the court and i was like dang i'm gonna
go say something but i didn't i never
said anything but
i'm a big fan for sure 100 i appreciate
you thank you robert and thank you
bless you appreciate you absolutely much
product
drive safe get out of here um so now and
so it's funny
because we have a question in here
somebody says what's one of your
favorite
moments uh or segments in the film and i
know for me
yes besides the amazing conversation
between miss giovanni and james baldwin
i also really was very fascinated by the
conversation between ellis and
minister farrakhan um and
and and obviously as a queer black
person
it it was a very unique conversation it
was one that i was not aware of
um so and it's a it's it's a
it's a tricky one you know it's you
watching somebody two people watch it
walk a tightrope um because of but also
there's a level of respect
that that was sort of there between the
two men and i love it if you two could
because that's one of my favorite
segments in the movie i love that you
two could speak to that
that segment and what you guys were
thinking about and then also if you
wouldn't mind speaking to some of your
your favorite moments from the show
go first i want to go first nikki
obviously my my favorite is going to be
when we have the women
doing the poetry reading putting that
together was so cool
that was so wonderful because you hadn't
seen what was that five women six women
sent in on stage black women
reading poetry that said what they
wanted to say that really was
probably one of my if not the uh i like
what i do with jimmy too i mean don't
misunderstand but
putting that together it was just
wonderful to see black women uh doing
that and
there was um uh what was that young
young group
uh ice you know not the last poets
no there were those they were three boys
you know black ivory black ivory
i loved watching them but ellis brought
a lot of people on stage who we would
not have seen
and that's why i mentioned um i
mentioned ed sullivan because he used to
bring strange
not strange but different groups kind of
strange
he would bring different groups together
and ed sullivan you know everybody you
know where everybody in america was on
sunday night
because they were sitting in front of
the television looking at ed sullivan
in the black community you knew where we
were because we were like
also watching seoul and i think that
we were talking earlier but i think we
need that kind of uh
variety show because right now we don't
we only have this
side you agree with or decide you don't
agree with so i think it would be
and i like the music i like having i
like the conversation
i like the people making their
statements but i love the music that
that the youngsters would come in yeah
blackout that's what that's lovely you
know
i i watched the kids come in and you
watched
uh that's how i met nina simone you
watch nina come
in and she's going to sing sometime but
you also she played a fabulous fabulous
piano
and she could you know oh wow
people didn't know that you could that
you could do that
i was always sorry that we weren't able
to get
leon team price or jesse norman on oh
which we couldn't do for a lot of
reasons it was it was just me it was
money for one thing
but god wouldn't have just been
wonderful to have ms price
sing a spiritual or to have miss norman
or miss
miss price sing from porgy invest let's
just open the show
with melissa what about what yes
absolutely melissa what about you what
were some of your favorite moments and
what are your thoughts on the fair con
conversation yes i want to talk about
the fair con because
i had a lot of reservations about that
and i'm
because i know how he and there are very
mixed feelings about him
there he's quite has been and continues
to be reviled in the united states but
then he also
leads the nation of islam and so there's
there's it's
almost like a duality that he inhabits
very much the way ellis did and what
we chose to show it you know because i
realized
how can i censor him 50 years later if
they didn't censor ellis
in you know 1972 then is it my place to
censor and not show that so what i
decided to do was
was pick the part of the episode
where it shows ellis's bravery because
it that was what was important to me was
how was ellis responding and how was
ellis challenging uh farrakhan in that
he was
bringing to the fore the fact that the
nation of islam was
notoriously homophobic and so
i just thought that was so powerful that
ellis hayslip
as a queer black man could stand in his
truth
and challenge him about something that
was
really his entire being and represented
so much more at that moment
because here are two men and what what's
fascinating when you watch that is
it's like game recognizes game because
ellis on the one hand is giving him a
platform
for what he does but he's also
challenging him and taking him to task
for what's wrong with
what's going down in the nation but at
the same time they have to respect each
other because
that there's that sense of community
that we have in the black
family like we will not tear each other
down we may be diametrically opposed but
normally we won't and so that was
interesting to me too
that layer of of love
respect and disagreement and so
i i wanted ellis to emerge as a hero in
that moment and to stand in that truth
and so that's why i decided
to show that part i'm curious how you
felt about it no i mean i thought
yeah i thought it was it was beautifully
done and i think that it reminded me
of times you know when you're the queer
black kid at thanksgiving you know
uh a little bit figuratively you know
that you have
an uncle you have an aunt you have a
cousin who
is family but doesn't necessarily
agree with what they may deem as a life
choice
and but there still has to be respect
sometimes
given to those that may not always see
you completely
and that can be very difficult and i
think he he basically
represented all of us in that moment you
know and i thought it was really
beautifully done
so thank you for showing me that because
i didn't know that existed i didn't know
that the conversation ever happened and
nobody was really talking about that on
especially in public television and
certainly not a black man you know
standing up
for uh you know same gender loving folks
that that wasn't even
possible at that time right in the
united states
anywhere really so it really showed
um so much strength and pride
and he didn't flinch you know he just
sat there and he asked the question
and yeah no on the one hand i'm going to
support you and i'm going to fill the
whole audience with nation of islam so
you'll be preaching to the choir
yeah on the other hand i've got a really
important thing to show you
and let's see what you do let's see how
we how we do
and at the end they both emerge intact
but there has been
a breach in a way like a a demanding of
respect
and at least uh that's why i love how i
having thomas alan harris talk about it
and to see
how he felt at it about it as a queer
black man and what
what that meant to him in that moment
and um
that was really important to show
because it showed ellis standing in his
truth which he always did
absolutely and a question that keeps
popping up in the q a as well as
where can people see episodes of the
show
yes yes okay luckily there are 24
body conversations that is on youtube
yes
you can actually see 24 full episodes
y'all if you go to if you have amazon
prime
they just went up on amazon prime so you
can watch all 24
um some of the best episodes then if you
don't have prime
uh if you are a member of pbs passport
you can watch there but it's not some
memberships like
paywall but you can also watch it's
shout factory tv which is free
and to be tv and pluto tv and then there
are
a few stragglers you know people have
uploaded their own bootleg copies
on on youtube too of course because
that's what you do
but you can see those intact and
i'm hoping that this conversation that
happens out of the film
constantly in the community will help
build an awareness around this
extraordinary archive because it really
is a treasure trove you know
it's just amazing and i hope that maybe
you know it will inspire
uh the whole series to be re-released
or made again maybe that's fine yeah
absolutely uh mr giovanni how important
was that time for you to be a part of
this this you know i don't even want to
call it a resurgence because we've
always been here
but what was it like for you to be
at the forefront and to be at the center
really of this show
that would really kind of exist as a
time capsule for all of us
well first of all you have to admit we
didn't know it was the time castle
npr had offered um ellis
the opportunity i don't know how that
happened something melissa might have i
just knew it did
and people were just dealing with young
poets like me
and so when ellis asked me what did i
think
and that's what that really amounted to
what did i think
i knew a couple of things and i share
that with anybody out there i knew i
didn't want to work
for npr because if i started to work for
npr
i would lose my ability to eat pbs
yeah and uh i said okay but yeah of
course
like ellison i've always remembered uh
and melissa you probably heard it but uh
ellis was always saying you know
duke ellington owes me and i would fall
for this every time some of their best
and you'd say well why does duke
ellington know you ellis and he said
because you know he was down you know
all of the oil from dc
and he said he was he was in new york
and he was trying to get to harlem
and he asked my aunt how did he get to
harlem and she said
um you take the a train and
every time and we fell for it every time
and
uh he was he was a lot of fun to be
around
and of course he was a producer so he
did do very well and i can think of a
couple of people
as i'm thinking about it who also right
now in new york
i'm not in new york anymore but i
thought it was good
to be invited to be a part of it as a
part of my
generation and when asked my answer
is always going to be yes but at the end
of that year of that first year
ellis snooki owed me because he hadn't
been paying me
and he said what what what would you
what can i do i owe you what can i do
and i said oh ellis i would really love
to talk to james baldwin
and he said well i know jimmy and i was
just like
you know james but you know i was like
and he said yeah he said i'll call him
and baldwin said oh i'd love to talk to
nikki giovanni but
um he was in uh uh uh his his place in
in uh
i don't have time to come to the united
states
would you mind coming to london and so
ella said that i said you gotta be
kidding i'd walked in london to talk to
jamie baldwin
and so i went to london of course it was
wonderful
and the show was shot in london and you
can
see the difference when you look at that
you can see the difference
because jimmy and i talk with our hands
and so
the british shoot that way and so you'll
see that
we're we're all talking with our hands
we're all doing things like that
and the uh it was shot very uh
interestingly
and jimmy is a night owl as some of you
if you know him at all
knew him uh he was a night owl so we
would
start shooting at like about eight
o'clock and we'd shoot for a couple of
hours
and then he'd go off with his friends
and have dinner or whatever
i would go to my son with me i'd go to
bed
you know and so we were shooting at
night it was really and again it was
wonderful
because it was in everybody's time in
terms of how
how it worked but my son of course like
everybody fell in love with mr bowman
and so thomas his name was simons he
when thomas
when we went to breakfast jimmy was
coming in from being out with his
friends he knew everybody
and so thomas would say jimmy baldwin
jimmy bone take me for a walk
and you know i'm sure bob was like oh my
god
and he didn't want to and thomas would
pull on him until he did it
and uh we would take he would take my
son for a walk
which was really nice and by then he was
ready to go to bed
and i would uh of course i took thomas
uh around and showed him london
so it was um and i think the show
showed a lot of a relationship that that
sort of
grew and uh not sort of but it did grow
and i'm very uh lucky i have a
photograph that gerald cremans took
of uh baldwin and me and i have on a
scarf i no longer have
and i it sits right there i look at it
every day when i get in my car because
it's in my garage
i look at it every day i look at it
every day because it's right there
when i get in my car that's what i see
is i see i see baldwin
and i think that that kind of
opportunity i
recently and i don't want to hog but i
recently did a conversation
with rhapsody but uh somebody said well
what are you doing i said yes
and rhapsody is a young woman and so i
thought as an older yeah she's about the
same
age i was 20 years younger
than jimmy and she got 20 years younger
a little bit more than 20 years younger
than i am so
i thought yeah we owe each other that
and that's what
like that does show how we how we talk
to each other how
how the generations yeah
absolutely and it's so important and i
think melissa i think is important for
people to know
that ellis did coordinate that
conversation and so many conversations
and so many opportunities
for for us to be able to look at
ourselves
that's the great thing is that he he
took the best of us
and put us on television and so we at
home
say oh that is who we are that we're
poetic we're musical we're
you know we're radical uh you know we're
vulnerable and and i think that's what i
really saw
and also someone did have um you know i
think i think we have we have a hard
album i think we have
five more minutes somebody did want to
ask about the music and the film
not just the music that you're showing
which is iconic and amazing like i mean
like the
simpsons thing is like blows my mind but
people also are wondering about the
music you use for the
cues and well how was that super
expensive cause i know about music cues
they can be really tricky
and obvious there's a ton of like music
and stuff if you're featuring i mean
patti labelle singing
somewhere with rainbow this how did you
navigate all that stuff
you saw me rear back
[Applause]
the thing about the the music and i know
robert would feel this way i can't speak
for him but i know
he told me so that you know what we
wanted to do in the film was to make
the music a character because the story
of soul
is the story of the people and the music
of our lives the music of our soundtrack
and
the struggle the the sexiness the beauty
the difficulty it's all there and and
that's so much of what soul was
as a show and so we wanted to make sure
that the
music like the the the sound bed
the soundtrack of our lives was in this
film and was
evolving just as the show was evolving
and and
it was whatever was happening in the
zeitgeist was represented in the music
as well
and so we knew like we had to have
quintessential soul music in there
and everything that would really
represent the time
and what we were feeling and the
connections that we have to that music
and so it was a challenge because we had
something like i think 156 cues or
something there's a lot of music
yeah and and i you know
i know my music supervisor is out there
shaking his head right now because
you know i had it in the list and he was
like um
you know and i said we can't compromise
you know we got to hear this we got to
hear that
we need to hear king floyd you know we
need to hear express yourself
like everything has a purpose and it
really illustrates the moment
and we knew that whatever we weren't
going to use musically because we had to
create like for the filmmakers out there
we we did have a favorite nations
contract
between all of the publishers and that
was the only way we could
you know afford it i mean that's really
yeah
shout out to favorite nations in
addition you know
it was like how do we choose and what
whatever we're not using
we're going to illustrate through the
score and so that's where robert's
genius came
in because he could even come in and go
oh yeah well we need a little coal train
vibe in there
okay let's do these changes and then
they'd hit it and literally record it
in one take and it was just amazing so
we recorded the whole film
in two days with all of those views so
he was working with geniuses you know
well well i i think
well i think that's wonderful i think
one of my favorite music cues uh
possibly where i'm from i mean we hear
half the way in the in the womb when
you're
and um and it's funny because actually
there's like a donnie hathaway tattoo i
finally found but i want to get but
beautifully yeah i know it's like it's
like it says finally i figured it out
but
uh his voice is like it means so much to
me and to so many particularly a lot of
obviously chicagoans but just to us as a
as a culture and
really it means a lot and there's a
heartbreaking story about ellis losing
his sister
and his nephew um and for that that for
donnie's voice to come in the way it
does
it's a beautiful piece of editing it's a
beautiful piece of way to use that song
and it's a great way to use his voice
because i think his voice in a way
it is it is the most soulful melancholy
his place represents more you know and
uh and at the end to me that he's just
so beautiful and so beautifully done
is when i was already in the whole time
but to have that moment punch me in the
gut
it was really you know and that's
exactly what i
what i felt was there is if there is one
song
that illustrates anguish and pain and
love and
deep deep soulful connection it's a song
for you
and i remembered that it was
played at ellis's memorial as well
and it was choreographed by alvin ailey
with a beautiful tribute
to him and it was um it was the most
extraordinary thing and it just
hit me to the core but i've always loved
that song and so i knew
what is the universal like language of
loss
and love for us culturally it's a song
for you there's nothing else
boom it's done you know and by the same
token we had to
start the film with donnie too because
we were like that's going to be the bed
when when you hear him sing the ghetto
and the struggle of
black people in the beginning knowing
that that was the beginning
and that we would end with his legacy
his
daughter leila hathaway and so we start
with
donnie and we end with leila and she's
like the legacy of soul
and so when rob g wrote that song called
show me your soul we knew that that was
going to be the end song and that she
had to take us home
that's amazing we only have one more
minute but i want to ask you guys oh i
could be here all night
i know but listen i'll give you the last
word since you're our filmmaker but i'll
start with this honey
what would you want or what would you
think ellis would have wanted his legacy
to be
oh wow
to do it right to do it right
and and he really did work on doing it
right
there was no halfway to seoul he did it
right and i think that he would want
that let's just me i think that he would
want that
as his legacy let's do it right
i agree i agree thank you mr giovanni
you're a legend and you're an icon and
we're grateful for you
thank you so much we love you yeah
melissa
i would say um
that black seeds keep on growing and i
think he
there was a reason that just sidebar he
says that in the last episode of seoul
in march of 73 and he's actually reading
from
a telegram that came in from patti
labelle
to encourage him and she wrote you know
although it's over it's not the end
black seeds keep on growing and we also
know that that is the lyrics from a song
by the main ingredient
of course um but i thought that that was
so
important because he's he has laid these
seeds and he knew
that even though the show was canceled
you can't cancel seoul you can't cancel
black folks
you know he curated the culture and he
gave it to us
but just to show us what's coming next
and this idea that of perseverance
and and um and owning that perseverance
because we are survivors you know
baldwin says the same thing we have
survived until now
that's right we have been through
something yeah and i think that that
is the legacy of ellis is that he knew
that he was at the beginning of things
but that all he had to do was lay these
lay this seed bed
if you will and that would encourage us
to know our our beauty and our
brilliance
i think he was in love with black
culture and
so if there's like this love affair with
black culture and he never wanted us
to forget and so when we made this film
that was the whole idea was
to remind people of their
beauty and their excellence absolutely
no i i think that's that's
beautifully said i think you both are a
big part of his legacy
uh and i think this movie will make sure
that
whatever forgets what his legacy is and
that we are the legacy
and i love the that those friends of the
black seas keep on growing
they always will uh you are the legacy
leader
you know what you're doing and you know
i'm sitting at the feet you know taking
notes and being mindful
um and i want to just encourage everyone
in in here tonight
please tell all the people you know to
go find it what's the quickest way most
of them that they can go to
the site yeah
okay go go to the site please check it
out we're going to keep talking about it
it's already getting a bunch of awards a
lot of
people talking about the film because it
because because you know what as mr
giovanni said you did it right
you did it you did it the right way and
um i know
ellis would be proud and and i'm honored
to be aware
of who he is and what he did in his
great contributions so thank you so much
for
allowing me to moderate this amazing
conversation thank you to everyone for
being here thank you film independent
thank you josh you're the best i
appreciate you rachel
and um this has been an honor for me
truly melissa you know this has been
great and
miss giovanni just i mean such a
pleasure thank you so much
thank you josh thank you film
independent
thank you thank you everyone and as
ellis would say it's been beautiful
yeah it's been beautiful so thank you
all thanks everybody and wish you the
best with this
i mean i want to see it go all the way
come on academy come on academy just oh
speak it let's speak it okay right thing
do the right thing academy and give them
this uh nomination
for best documentary that's what it
deserves
yep all right okay thank you thank you
everyone thank you for joining us
and if you haven't seen it please watch
the movie again as everybody you know to
go check it out